ist es nicht vielleicht einfach die
bittere wahrheit dass wir in afghanistan
nicht gewinnen können ich möchte nicht
in einer nation leben wo mir
irgendwelche religiösen gruppen sagen
was ich zu glauben habe oder was ich zu
machen habe sollte man frauen geld dafür
bieten dass sie bei den taliban unter
der burka bleiben als bundesregierung
ich finde das ist eine ganz gemeine
frage also wenn man sie hatten die leute
ihre kinder an die us soldaten geben das
kleine kind abgeben da kann man ja nicht
sagen ja die haben gerade keine angst
weil ich bin
[Musik]
die wissen seit 2014 dass wir aus
afghanistan abziehen werden war nicht
genau bekannt wann aber man hätte
vorbereitungen treffen muss man hat
keine getroffen und die einzige
vorbereiten die jetzt bekannt gewordene
christ bis das man mitarbeitern der
gesellschaft für internationale
zusammenarbeit das ist die
entwicklungshilfeorganisation der
bundesrepublik deutschland gesagt hat
wenn ihr euch nicht auf die liste zum
retten setzen last durch dir ein
jahresgehalt das in einem land wo alle
banken geschlossen sind ziemlich
skandalös es geht weiter wir haben
menschen die sich bei uns melden die
haben 13 jahre für die gez gearbeitet
allerdings nicht die letzten zwei jahre
sondern die hand vor drei jahren
aufgehört aber die sind bekannt weil sie
so lange dafür gearbeitet die kommen
überhaupt nicht auf die liste die
kriegen auch nicht so ein angebot ich
finde das ist schäbig mit solchen
menschen die für uns gearbeitet haben
die unsere werte repräsentiert haben die
versucht haben dort aufbauarbeit zu
machen so umzugehen dass man sagt wenn
wir uns in ruhe lasst dann zahlen wir
euch ein jahresgehalt von brauchen
vielleicht am ersten abend bei der
premiere von viertel nach acht
historischer fernsehmoment ihren trittin
und ich komplett einer meinung ich hätte
mir nicht vorstellen können dass wir
jetzt tatsächlich versuchen olaf scholz
war gestern hier bei uns bei bild live
und hat gesagt nein es handelt sich
natürlich in keiner weise um irgendeine
form von da bleibt premier das hätte
damit nichts zu tun man wollte den
menschen etwas gutes tun ich sehe das
ganz genauso über den text lesen wenn
man den text hieß es ist genau das und
nachdem wir 20 jahre lang gegen dieses
regime gekämpft haben versuchen wir
jetzt tatsächlich menschen zu bestechen
damit sie freiwillig weiter unter dem
regime leben der mit dem unterließen
barbaren weiterleben und das auch noch
für ein jahresgehalt was wir vermutlich
niemals wirklich ausbezahlen können oder
was dann vermutlich von den taliban mit
100 prozent vermögenssteuer einkassiert
werden wird für mich ein absoluter
skandal
man kann es nicht sein dass einige auch
bleiben wollen weil es ihrer heimat ist
oder geworden ist ich würde sagen wenn
wir uns im moment den flughafen von
kabul ein und sieht es eher so aus als
würden viele riecht bleiben oder wie
sieht das ich will mich gar nicht
ausschließen dass einzelne bleiben
wollen es gibt ich kenne auch so ganz
tapfere von vom world food program die
waren schon unter den taliban und so da
aber
anzustiften dazu bleiben weil man sie
nicht rausholen will weist für auf und
das schäbig und jeder der das trotzdem
machen will hat meinen tiefen respekt
und da rede ich auch gerne davon wie man
den unterstützen soll aber eine
konditionierung wenn du kein antrag
stellt dass wir nicht raus holen dann
kriegst du geld das geht zeigt das dass
dieses ganze thema flüchtlings debatte
oder die furcht davor dass es eine neue
flüchtlingswelle gibt vielleicht doch
viel größer ist als man sich das im
wahlkampf moment zugesteht glaube ich
schon also ich das ist natürlich ein
hochemotionales thema und wir sind ja
zogen also in unserer siegermentalität
liebe deinen nächsten wie dich selbst
das ist ganz klar es ist natürlich in
afghanistan etwas passiert seit vielen
vielen jahren wo man versucht hat einem
land eine art von beglückung zuzumuten
die nicht stattgefunden hat ich erinnere
mich damals also aus meiner jugend und
das ist lange her wo man einfach es
richtig fand das missionare nach afrika
gegangen sind um dort das liebe jesulein
bekannt zu machen und das kinder ob sie
es nun wollten oder nicht getauft wurden
natürlich verbunden mit viel
verbesserung für die bevölkerung schulen
was auch immer kultivierung von
landstrichen aber heute sagt man das war
nicht in ordnung dass man diesen leuten
eine art von glaubens doktrin auf impfen
wollte mit der sie wieder an etwas
anfangen konnten noch die sie brauchten
noch die sie glücklicher gemacht hat und
ich weiß nicht wie weit die politische
situation in afghanistan am anfang ja
eben eine art von von versuch war eine
heile welt eine heile welt zu schaffen
und jetzt sind wir bei
aufräumungsarbeiten ob die gut gehen
können weiß ich nicht und eine
afghanische sage ich mal kämpferin für
die rechte der frauen in trier oder wo
auch immer wie sie jetzt hinbringen
wirkt dann auch ein bisschen wie fish
out of water das ist so dahin gesagt und
ich weiß nicht wie weit man da überhaupt
einen einen sage ich mal gerechten weg
finden kann und auch einen anständigen
weg aus dieser situation weil das möchte
ich ich möchte menschen aufgrund meiner
meiner völligen überzeugung ein recht
auf ein lebenswertes leben geben aber
die ganze welt ist wie leider jeden tag
sehen natürlich irgendwo aus dem tritt
geraten und wenn wir nun anfangen die
die welt in irgendeiner form nach
unserem gustav so zu verändern wie wir
es für richtig halten sprich demokratie
sprich verhältnisse dieser art dann
wissen wir dass wir uns damit verheben
und und die frage ist wie kommen wir aus
ich weiß es nicht ich weiß vieles nicht
und das ist etwas was mir heute auch
ganz wichtig ist es ist problematisch
wenn den fernsehsendungen promis sitzen
die versuchen den rest der welt diese zu
erklären ich habe sie selbst in dieser
form nicht begriffen ich bin im moment
in verschiedenen beziehungen siehe
corona siehe afghanistan ratlos zum
ersten mal in meinem leben weil wir auch
gemerkt haben dass diese diese
verantwortung die wir gerne auf die
politik geschoben haben dort ja nicht
wahrgenommen wird wir haben ja in dem
wahn gelebt dass ein willy brandt helmut
schmidt genau wissen was sie tun wir
merken jetzt plötzlich dass politiker
offensichtlich nicht wissen was sie tun
ob es zu meiner zeit richtig war weiß
ich nicht aber es ist nicht so hoch
geworden wie heute nina schenk und
patricia riekel sollte man frauen geld
dafür bieten dass sie bei den taliban
unter der burka bleiben als
bundesregierung ich finde das ist eine
ganz gemeine frage weil natürlich bis
man darauf sagen das war nein um gottes
willen natürlich nicht ja aber das ist
ein land mit einer ganz eigenen kultur
unter 20 jahren versuchen wir den unsere
werte auf zutritt zu vermitteln und wir
stellen jetzt fest dass es nicht
funktioniert das offenbar die afghanen
gar keine lust haben auf diese fremde
kultur und uns offenbar auch als
besatzungsmacht unseren die und anderen
nationen empfunden haben denn so schnell
wie die afghanische armee übergelaufen
ist zu den taliban die sind ja quasi mit
ausgebreiteten händen und strahlen auf
die zugelaufen also denke ich mir in
diesem land alle dass man sich ja
brechen nicht alle aber trotzdem die
gesamte armee super gelaufen und ich
weiß auch nicht aber die bilder am
flughafen sind ja schon herz zerreißen
als wenn man sie die leute ihre kinder
an die us soldaten geben das kleine kind
abgeben da kann man ja nicht sagen ja
die haben gerade keine angst die wollen
nicht fliehen ich bin ehrlich gesagt da
auch sehr stark herr trittin ich finde
hier zählt die menschlichkeit
parteiübergreifend aber was jetzt frau
sagen kann julian weniger mit ob die
taliban die frauen jetzt vor ort man den
geldschein sollte ich finde viel
schlimmer wenn ich durch twitter gehe
wenig durch instagram gehe der lifestyle
feminismus ist eigentlich überall also
jede frau ist heutzutage feministin und
jetzt gerade muss man ganz klar sagen wo
sind denn jetzt die frauen die
aufschreien was damit den frauen was
jetzt fehlt ein hangar soli war
großartig jetzt instagram account
gegründet jetzt immer geweigert den
brief gepostet es sind nur kleine taten
aber wenn ich sehe wie wir deutschen
frauen champagner trinken auf viel mehr
power main events gehen muss nie um
diese themen geht muss ich sagen wir
brauchen mal waren feminismus wir
brauchen jetzt initiativen in
deutschland diesen frauen zu helfen und
ich sollte vielleicht jetzt mal mehr
über die themen bei den ganz vielen
fällen minister in deutschland
gesprochen ein ganz großes problem dass
sich der feminismus oft nicht
entscheiden kann wie er es jetzt mit dem
islam oder besonders mit dem islamismus
hält auch in grünen kreisen durchaus ein
thema herr trittin was sagen sie zu der
frage ob wir frauen von der burka
befreien sollten wenn die frauen sich
davon selber befreien müssen sie dafür
unterstützt werden und wir müssen uns
mit solchen mails auseinandersetzen ich
persönlich bin was jede form von
religiös religion angeht der
schlechteste zeuge weil ich nicht
religiös bin ich habe mir angewöhnt das
zu respektieren was menschen glauben
aber es darf niemand gezwungen werden
und das ist die grenze und das bin ich
dann auch noch nicht sagen es geht gar
nicht um ich glaube wir sind in der die
nato ist in afghanistan gescheitert das
muss man so feststellen aber dass das
immer so geht fremde kultur auf
herrschen das finde ich jetzt auch ein
bisschen übertrieben ist es eine fremde
kultur auf herrschen wenn auch frauen in
schulen gehen wenn frauen an
universitäten gehen das ist übrigens in
iran möglich das ist eine andere
auslegung des islam auch eine andere
richtung als ein schiitischer
ausrichtung aber ist das eigentlich
typisch für die kultur afghanistan
frauen im hause zu halten und für dumm
zu erklären und wenn sie sich dagegen
verstoßen sie mit den übelsten strafen
zu überziehen ich glaube nicht und das
haben viele afghanen auch anders gehen
das ist noch viel weniger als wenn wir
sagen wir bringen da investments
ich finde solche basisrechte die müssen
gewahrt sein und dafür haben viele
deutsche und internationale menschen
gearbeitet haben soldaten für gekämpft
ihr leben riskiert da haben
entwicklungshilfe für gearbeitet auch
häufig ihr leben dafür riskiert und dass
wir dort jetzt abziehen müssen das ist
nicht nur für die afghanen bitter
sondern auch für die menschen die sich
da engagiert und sein kollege paul
ronzheimer war ja in afghanistan hat
dort mit taliban gesprochen der mir
einen bemerkenswerten satz gesagt dass
frauen natürlich vor die tür dürfen und
zwar wenn sie die tiere füttern gehen es
gibt aber noch einen ganz anderen punkt
ist es natürlich im moment sehr bequem
immer über frauenrechte zu reden die
möchte am ende jeder verteidigen jeder
verteidigt gerne minderheiten aber es
gibt ja noch die andere frage leben wir
vielleicht jetzt alle auf einmal viel
unsicherer weil der internationale
islamistische terrorismus einen
gigantischen sieg erfahren hat ist es
nicht vielleicht einfach die bittere
wahrheit dass wir in afghanistan nicht
gewinnen können aber dass wir trotzdem
dann am ende jahr für immer in
afghanistan bleiben müssen einfach um
sicherzustellen dass dort die leute die
alleine level der von tradecentre
attackiert haben nie wieder in diesem
land unterschlupf finden auch wenn es
unbequem ist auch wenn es politisch
keine besonders schöne botschaft ist
würde ich mal sagen das ist nicht so
sehr ein militäreinsatz das ist vielmehr
ein polizeieinsatz der niemals endet und
der dazu da ist menschen die uns hier
die art und weise wie wir leben kaputt
bomben wollen unter druck zu setzen so
dass sie ihren kopf nicht aus ihren
höhlen heben können um eben diese
terroranschläge gegen uns zu planen und
dann wie auch durchzuführen die frage
kann ihnen doch zurzeit niemand
beantworten der deal den tramp
geschlossen hat nicht beiden kamp lautet
ihr kriegt das land und ihr garantiert
im gegenzug dafür dass ihr und niemand
sonst aus afghanistan uns angreift und
ob dieser deal der ohne sicherheiten
geschlossen wonach ein schlechter deal
dieser deal trägt weiß ich nicht ich bin
persönlich sehr skeptisch die andere
entscheidung die getroffen worden ist
die dann auch von joe biden getroffen
ist wie sie trump auch getroffen hat war
dass die usa aufhören wollten selber in
sogenannten forever wars also für immer
engagiert zu sein das ist vor dem
hintergrund der debatte auch in den usa
der in politischen lagers bei
republikanern wie bei demokraten eine
sehr sehr verbreitete haltung und ich
bin tue mich ein bisschen schwer zu
sagen hättet ihr mal weiter gemacht wie
alle wissen wenn die nicht weitermachen
hätte es auch nichts genutzt wenn wir da
geblieben wären ich frage mich gibt es
nicht in afghanistan irgendwann eine
entwicklung ich meine 20 jahre lang
haben frauen und auch die intelligenz
normal leben können sie konnten zur uni
gehen sie konnten arbeiten die mädchen
zur schule gegangen ist es so dass die
sich jetzt alle zurückziehen und sagen
wir haben angst oder gibt es in diesem
volk inzwischen trotzdem eine eine
entwicklung dass man gut man hat jetzt
angst vor diesen wilden jungen männern
mit diesem bärtigen auf den
pressekonferenzen die die taliban geben
sieht man ja nur männer und die reden
dann über frauen die über randgruppen
wir wollen die natürlich integrieren und
so weiter sie dürfen auch weiter zur
schule gehen haben sie gesagt in dieser
konferenz
aber ich vertraue auch darauf dass sich
menschen entwickeln dass sich
gesellschaften entwickeln und wenn man
türen geöffnet hat man kann nicht alle
schließen und darauf vertraue ich ja
denn ich mache diese frauen die
gearbeitet haben die gelehrt haben die
mädchen diese schule gegangen sind
die haben ja auch irgendwo einen hohen
einfluss auf die männer vielleicht
verändert sich da etwas also das ist
sozusagen meine meine hoffnung ich
glaube auch dass in der tat die größte
leistung unserer abendländischen kultur
die säkularisierung gewesen ist die
trennung von staat und kirche ich möchte
nicht in einer nation leben wo mir
irgendwelche religiösen gruppen sagen
was ich zu glauben habe oder was ich zu
machen habe und das ist etwas was ich
nicht begreifen dass diese jungen männer
die nun auch mit youtube oder was auch
immer groß wären nicht die diesen diesen
gedanklichen schritt vollziehen können
dass liberalismus dass das gefühl in
freiheit sich ausleben zu können dass
das web eine nation zusammenhält und nur
so kann ja glück entstehen dass diese
verbohrtheit aufgrund von religiösen
vorgaben nicht in irgendeiner form sich
in unserer zeit erledigt das begreife
ich nicht weil sonst alles in
irgendeiner form durch youtube tutorials
geklärt wird das offensichtlich nicht
also dieser dieser schritt in die
freiheit gibt es richtig ist was es gibt
ist kaum 50 jahre her dass das frauen
selber entscheiden konnten ob sie ein
bankkonto eröffnen und sonst was hat es
mit diesen aufgaben entwickelt während
meiner lehrzeit die erlaubnis ihres
mannes brauchten um einen führerschein
machen zu gehen das war mir nicht
bewusst erfüllt mich mit tiefstem
entsetzen wie kann sowas sein ja es ist
nicht lange her dass ein bisschen von
dieser ideologie auch noch in unserem
land steckte spannende diskussion bisher
wir melden uns gleich wieder bei viertel
[Musik]